[Music]
here's the best video you'll see all day
whoops own dropped the new rap battle
between the favorite characters with a
limited vocabulary
Hodor faces off with Groot in an epic
but repetitive rap dude I am I am Groot
did you really think that this stark
servant and sentient tree were super
dumb no actually they're brilliant
lyricists on par with jay-z and
Shakespeare but that's not all there's a
secret easter egg hidden within the
video if you didn't able the closed
captions you'll be able to see the
lyrics of the rap battle on screen as
Hodor and groot take turns insulting
each other here are the best lines and
[Music]
[Music]
Oh too much too much if you dug this
video you can hit like you can comment
with who you thought delivered the
sickest burns subscribe if you like what
we're giving you here okay don't you
still just do it cuz I'm asking you to
just do it
out of your heart I'm Gabe Hill writer
and I want to formally issue my
challenge to a rap battle with Drake
character on Degrassi
I feel confident he probably won't even
show don't send this down
[Music]